y nos dicen que consideremos los
siguientes datos aquí tengo las horas y
los kilómetros y bueno aquí tengo que en
cinco horas una partícula o una cosa ha
viajado 35 kilómetros en 15 horas está
este objeto ha viajado 110 kilómetros en
40 horas este objeto ha viajado 300
kilómetros y bueno lo que yo me quiero
preguntar en este problema es cuál
debería de ser la escala que debería
tener la gráfica para considerar estos
datos y bueno date cuenta que nos dan
distintas opciones las cuales nos dan
distintos caminos para dibujar estas
gráficas es decir distintas escalas para
cada uno de los ejes por ejemplo aquí
nos dicen que en la primera opción en la
opción tenemos una escala de dos para lg
chem ok mientras que para el eje acá nos
dan una escala de 200 enelvén o una
escala de 1 para el eje h mientras que
el eje acá nos da en una escala de 50 y
así todos los demás
lo que yo quiero que hagas en este
momento es que pause el vídeo y pienses
cuál es la escala más apropiada para
graficar estos datos que nos dan cuál de
estas cuatro escalas es la mejor para
considerar estos datos muy bien es
momento de pausar el vídeo
ok ahora lo que vamos a buscar son las
gráficas de estos datos que nos dan y
para eso lo que quiero que veas es que
las horas van a llevar a los kilómetros
por lo tanto esta es la variable
independiente y esta es la variable
dependiente y por lo tanto vamos a poner
las horas en el eje horizontal así que
déjame tener aquí el suficiente espacio
para poner cuatro de ellas ok esto no me
gusta lo voy a hacer un poco más pequeño
a algo más o menos así en este eje voy a
poner las horas ok y en este eje en el
eje vertical voy a poner la distancia ok
y vamos a escribirlo la distancia está
dada en kilómetros entonces le voy a
poner una cara ok mientras que este otro
eje está dado en horas
horas y es el tiempo ahora déjame poner
algunas líneas genéricas aquí voy a
dividirlo en uno ok en dos en tres en
cuatro en cinco en seis ok y de igual
manera puede hacer lo mismo para el eje
de las casas voy a dividirlo en uno en
dos en tres en cuatro en cinco en seis
de lujo ahora como ésta va a ser mi base
de gm ha de tomarme por aquí y la voy a
copiar y pegar cuatro veces ok vamos a
copiar la íbamos a pegarla una vez más
ok este va a ir más o menos por acá ok
la voy a pegar otra vez más este va a ir
más o menos por acá algo así y le voy a
poner otra vez más ya está la voy a
poner más o menos como por aquí
ahora ya tengo mis cuatro gráficas y
ahora vamos a pensar en la primera de
ellas en la gráfica a si te das cuenta
en la gráfica amd lo que nos dicen aquí
lo voy a poner que es la gráfica amd es
que tenemos una escala del eje hd2 y la
escala del eje acá de 200 así que vamos
a ponerlo el eje de las haches va de dos
en dos
entonces aquí iría un dos aquí y de un 4
aquí y de un 6 aquí un 8 aquí un 10
y aquí 112 ok esto me parece mientras
que en el otro eje va a una escala de
200 aquí iría 200 ok aquí iría 400 ok
aquí iría 600 ok aquí 800 ok y aquí iría
mil mil ahora vamos a intentar graficar
estos puntos justo en esta gráfica y el
primer punto me dice que cuando las
horas valen 5
cuando tenemos en colas este objeto ha
recorrido 35 kilómetros cuando nosotros
nos fijamos en las horas aquí podríamos
tener el valor de 5 más o menos entre el
4 y el 6 pero nuestro problema es que
necesitamos poner un punto
535 y si te das cuenta aquí no hay forma
de tomar el 35 en la mitad sería 100 la
mitad sería 50 y me quedaría muy pero
muy pegado al cero el 35 esta escala no
es tan apta para los kilómetros porque
nos quedarían muy pegados los valores al
origen y después nos fijamos en este que
es 15 bueno aquí le podríamos seguir 14
y entre el 14 y el 16 poner el 15 pero
aquí tendríamos el 110 el 110 estaría
como a la mitad y después si nos fijamos
en el 40 o el 40 ya está muy lejos el 40
está como por acá si nosotros seguimos
seguimos seguimos graficando el 40 nos
quedaría muy a la derecha y después
tenemos un valor de 300 que es entre
este y este es decir que todos los demás
valores no nos están diciendo mucho a
considerar los siguientes datos por lo
tanto no creo que sea la mejor opción la
gráfica y la gráfica amd no tienen la
mejor escala para poder hacer esto
inclusive podría quitar yo estos de acá
abajo podría quitar ello estos de acá
abajo
imagínate que yo los quito y bueno hay
otra forma de ponerlo si yo tomo aquí
este color y quito un poco de esto ok y
aquí en este momento yo pongo a dos
líneas de color rojo ok estoy diciendo
que voy a empezar desde un cierto número
voy a empezar desde un cierto número y
qué te parece si empezamos en el 5 si
nosotros empezamos en el 5 este sería el
valor de 5 déjenme ponerlo con este
color 5 y después hay que ir de dos en
dos aquí tendremos el 7 aquí tendríamos
el 9 aquí tendríamos el 11 aquí
tendríamos el 13 aquí tendríamos el 15 y
todos los demás pero date cuenta que
llegará al 40 sigue estando muy a la
derecha y el mismo problema pasa con el
eje de las casas por lo tanto parece ser
que esta no es mi respuesta correcta
la escala no es la mejor escala para
tomarnos estos datos así que voy a
tachar el inciso am que fue el primero
con el que empezamos y ahora vamos a
pensar en el inciso b y para eso déjenme
tomar este color voy a hablar del inciso
b y esta va a ser muy gráfica b ok y
vamos a poner en primer lugar la escala
la escala en el eje h va de uno en uno
así que empezaremos en 1 después 2
456 y todos los demás ok y la escala en
el eje cava en 50 aquí va en 50 100 ok
aquí va en 150 ok 200 de lujo y aquí va
en
250 bien aquí y está que seguiría sería
300 y bueno si nos damos cuenta a 800 no
espera aquí es 1000 aquí es 1000 le
falta un cero pero vamos a ver el
primero de ellos
535 ok cuando tenemos 5 horas estamos en
35 que es un poquito arriba de la mitad
de 50 estaríamos como por aquí ahora si
nos fijamos en la hora 15 bueno
podríamos extender un poco este eje y
decir 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
estaremos como por acá 15 110 nos
veríamos más o menos como por aquí sería
este punto 110
es un poco más abajo sería más o menos
así ok y bueno después tenemos el 40
pero aquí tenemos un problema para poner
40 de uno en uno estaremos muy pero muy
pero muy a la derecha nos salteamos
inclusive de este vídeo tendremos aquí
el 15 16 17 18 19 20 y ya no va a caber
el 40 falta mucho para el 40 por lo
tanto no creo que tampoco sean la mejor
la opción b de igual manera si nosotros
quitamos de aquí una parte y empezaremos
en 5 de 5 al 15 que habría sin ningún
problema tal es por acá pero del 15 al
40 está muy lejos por lo tanto la escala
en el eje h no es la mejor
fíjate que en el eje que no está tan mal
pero en el eje h está muy pero muy
pequeña entonces tampoco creo que sea la
mejor opción el inciso b inclusive no
aparecen todos los puntos pero bueno
vamos a fijarnos en el siguiente inciso
que es el inciso c ok vamos a poner que
aquí tenemos la gráfica
para esto déjenme bajar un poco en la
pantalla bajemos la un poco para camps
para poner bien en la escala ok la
escala va a ir de 5 en 5 en el eje h y
de 5 en 5 en el eje cam así que vamos a
ponerlo 5 10 ok 15 me parece bien 20
25 30 y bueno le puedo seguir y de igual
manera para camps tengo 5 10 15 20
25 y por acá tengo el 30 ahora vamos a
ver si entran estos puntos el primero es
el 535 vamos a ver el 535 cuando han
pasado cinco horas este objeto se
encuentra en 35 kilómetros ok tal vez
aquí está el 30 y lo podremos poner un
poquito más arriba por aquí tendríamos a
el 35 y entonces 5 35 se vería más o
menos graficado como por aquí ok ahora
el 15 el 15 si está bien en el eje de
las horas pero llegar al 110 de cinco en
cinco y ha parece estar bastante lejos
aquí está el 35 40 45 50 y 55 y nos
pasaríamos bastante podríamos hacer
crecer este eje bastante y entonces tal
vez poder graficar como por hasta acá el
valor de 15 110 15 110 sería como por
acá pero el valor de 40 300 creo que
esto ya no está en nuestras
posibilidades por aquí tendremos el 35 y
por acá al 40 eso lo podemos corregir
pero cuando nosotros intentemos llegar
al 300 en el eje acá entonces estaremos
pasando el vídeo de nuevo por lo tanto
no es la mejor opción esta escala
nosotros tal vez podríamos corregir este
eje y empezar no sé se me ocurre en 35
podríamos aquí empezar en 35 pero de
todas maneras cómo vamos de 55 sería 35
40 45 50 55 o 60
llegar a 300 sigue siendo bastante
grande por lo tanto tampoco creo que sea
la mejor opción el inciso c porque la
escala en el eje k es todavía reducida a
comparación de la escala en el eje h que
queda bastante bien así que vamos a
probar con el último de estos incisos
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con el
inciso de aquí voy a poner mi inciso de
ok y bueno la escala en el eje h es de 5
así que vamos a ponerla 5 10 15
20 25
30 ok y vamos a ver si les seguimos y la
escala en el eje camps es de 50 aquí va
50 ok por aquí va 100 ok por acá va
150-200 ok
250 vamos bien porque tendríamos el 300
el 300 es más para que no se vea montón
ado déjame hacer lo siguiente déjame
primero voy a quitar está acá de aquí la
voy a quitar y ahorita la voy a poner de
este lado entonces por acá tenemos el
valor de 300 que es con este color ok
por aquí tengo 300 y bueno la letra k la
voy a poner justo por acá aquí tenemos
al eje de las casas ok así que vamos a
poner los puntos a ambos puntos vamos a
tomar este color y el primer punto dice
cuando han transcurrido 5 horas 35
kilómetros 5 horas y bueno aquí tengo el
pse en cuenta la mitad del 50 es 25 así
que estamos un poquito más arriba de la
mitad un poquito más arriba de la mitad
de 50 bueno vamos a ver el siguiente 15
110 15 110 estaría como por aquí ok y si
nos acercamos a 15 estaríamos en este
punto de aquí cuando han transcurrido 15
horas hemos recorrido 110 kilómetros y
estamos justo por aquí el cual también
es un punto bastante razonable y entra
en este cuadrante se ve la diferencia
entre 35 kilómetros y 110 kilómetros
sigue 40
340 ok 40 no se ve aquí pero podemos
hacer crecer un poquito más este eje de
sánchez para que nos dé el valor de 40
para hacerlo crecer déjenme borrar un
poco esto voy a quitar esto de clint ok
voy a quitar esto de aquí y vamos a
hacer crecer un poco este eje así que me
quedaría a un poco para acá este eje ok
por acá tengo el eje h y bueno si aquí
tengo el 30 por acá tengo al 35 y por
acá tengo al 40 así que déjenme ponerlos
con su respectivo color aquí tengo al 35
y por acá tengo al 40 de lujo ahora yo
quiero fijarme en el 40
340 300 estará por aquí 40 300 ok si
cabe está justo por aquí el 40 300 y si
te das cuenta en este caso tenemos los
tres puntos en este cuadrante además se
ve claramente la diferencia entre cada
uno de los puntos por lo tanto sin
dudarlo creo que la mejor opción es el
inciso de la opción correcta y la opción
que yo tomaría es el inciso de porque si
se ve cada uno de los puntos los tres
están en este cuadrante y además se nota
la diferencia entre cada uno de ellos si
te das cuenta por ejemplo en el inciso
am estaba muy pegado el valor de 35 al
valor de 110 y entonces no se notaba
casi la diferencia y después teníamos el
valor de 300 aquí y todos los demás
valores en el eje camps no se utilizaban
aquí en el inciso b teníamos el problema
de que en el eje h íbamos del uno en uno
y graficar 40 el valor de 40 estaría muy
pero muy a la derecha por lo tanto creo
que tampoco era la opción correcta para
el eje h en el inciso c nosotros
llevamos de cinco en cinco en los dos
ejes y en el eje can tomar el valor de
300 no era nada viable porque de 5 a 300
a se saldría de este vídeo y entonces
tampoco es la mejor opción el eje k
queda chico mientras que en este en
nuestro inciso d
ustedes puntos aquí está el primero el
segundo y el tercero la escala es
bastante aceptable y si te das cuenta
además de que los tres puntos están en
este cuadrante podemos ver con mucha
claridad la diferencia entre cada uno de
ellos por lo tanto creo que la mejor
escala es el inciso de la escala en el
eje h de 5 mientras que la escalas del
eje acá es de 50